[Música]
bienvenidos a ello soy de france 24 en
medio de la pandemia de kobe 19 surgió
en la ciudad de mexico un centro de
ayuda integral para personas de la
comunidad lgtb temas es un espacio
seguro para quienes son sujetos de
persecución por su orientación sexual o
por su identidad de género entre las
personas que han recibido ayuda están
jóvenes que han sido forzados y forzadas
a recibir terapias de conversión para
curar la homosexualidad o para corregir
las supuestas desviaciones de género
esta situación de vulnerabilidad que
siempre han enfrentado los miembros de
la comunidad del egb temas en mexico se
recrudeció con la pandemia un grupo de
activistas tuvo la iniciativa de abrir
casa frida que da apoyo a víctimas de
discriminación del acoso en situaciones
que padecieron incluso al interior de
sus hogares
-mario carbonell y lisette romero tienen
la historia en ciudad de méxico
la homo lesbo transfobia suena como un
padecimiento raro pero en realidad es
una conducta de intolerancia hacia
alguien por su orientación sexual como
la que padeció con antonio carmona un
joven de 17 años que salió huyendo de su
casa ante las agresiones de sus propios
hermanos y la incomprensión de sus
padres por ser gay me quedo tres semanas
en la calle sin alimento sin dinero sin
nada viajando y buscando un espacio
donde quedarme
en plena pandemia en la ciudad de méxico
surgió casa frida más que un albergue es
un centro de ayuda integral para
personas de la comunidad lgtb que han
sufrido hostigamiento e incluso en el
entorno familiar a juan antonio además
de techo y comida le han ayudado a
tenerse confianza soy una persona de
autoestima muy bajo cuando llegué aquí
no podía ni siquiera hablar o pedir algo
ni siquiera levantar la cara y pues en
eso es lo que me ayudaba en subir mi
autoestima en la ciudad de mexico se
prohibieron por ley las supuestas
terapias para curar la homosexualidad
como si fuera una enfermedad y que en
realidad son tratos crueles y
degradantes como explica raúl está por
al codirector del refugio acá en casa
frida hemos recibido a personas que
vienen huyendo de estos espacios de
conversión que hemos inclusive que he
tenido que rescatar de sus hogares no
cuando nos hacen un llamado de auxilio
no todos los residentes son tan jóvenes
como juan antonio es el caso de vanesa
martel quien por la grave violencia que
sufrió por homofobia fue admitida a
pesar de
54 años ahí sufrí pues este
golpes físicos cuatro personas me
violaron y me maltrataron me dejaron
que esté bloqueado mi mente en blanco
aquí le han brindado terapia psicológica
y como a los demás le han dado talleres
y cursos pues el objetivo es reinsertar
los con éxito a la sociedad caza freda
me ha brindado y me ha dado la
oportunidad de volver a vivir de volver
a sentirme y de recuperar mi identidad a
cuatro meses de abrir la casa tuvo que
mudarse a esta nueva sede pues
recibieron amenazas de muerte de vecinos
homofóbicos aquí continuarán con el
proyecto de lograr que las víctimas
salgan de nuevo con la cara en alto
nos acompaña desde ciudad de méxico kin
castañeda ella es activista feminista
defensora de los derechos humanos de las
minorías y también promotora del
matrimonio igualitario en su país la
bienvenida france24 un gusto saludarla
muchas gracias angela un saludo a
quienes nos escuchan mire este es un
tema que es muy complicado de manejar
hay muchísima vulnerabilidad de por
medio- muchísima discriminación como ha
sido manejada la defensa de los derechos
humanos de esta comunidad tan diversa
durante la pandemia usted siendo una de
las abanderadas
y desde luego él
en el momento en el que viene el
confinamiento pues deja al descubierto
lo que de manera cotidiana conocíamos
que son todos estos casos de exclusión y
de violencia que se dan en el entorno
familiar en la casa en el hogar y que
por supuesto pues solamente había podido
ser acompañados y arropados como un
refugio en aquellas familias sociales es
decir cuando una lesbiana un homosexual
o una persona trans era despreciada en
su casa por su mamá por su papá por sus
y por su familia sus primos etcétera
quedaba siempre la posibilidad de
salir de casa a transitar en la escuela
en el trabajo y es ahí donde se conforma
esa familia social que de alguna forma
brinda estabilidad y acompañamiento a
quienes han perdido ese respeto en su
familia sin embargo al estar en
cuarentena en este confinamiento 24
horas conviviendo con con las personas
que son las agresoras con esas personas
con esa mamá con ese tío a quien bien
que nos desprecia ha agudizado de manera
significativa esa violencia
bueno usted es activista por el
matrimonio igualitario uno de los puntos
de esta lucha que usted han remarcado a
través de los años es que el matrimonio
no puede concebirse como una unión con
fines reproductivos y yo le traigo esto
a colación porque precisamente muchos de
los problemas en pandemia han surgido
desde el hogar de todas estas personas
que se han sentido discriminadas
desde una concepción de familia que es
mamá y papá la concepción de una familia
heterosexual entonces por favor hablemos
de desde donde debería conseguirse de la
familia para que exista no solo
tolerancia sino comprensión de la
diferencia
sí desde luego hay tres temas que deja
de manera grave en evidencia la pandemia
y uno de ellos en la movilidad forzada
que se da en el marco del confinamiento
y que esta movilidad
es estrictamente para salvar la vida si
es las lesbianas los homosexuales y esas
personas trans no huyen de su hogar en
ocasiones no salvan la vida entonces es
un tema muy delicado porque tampoco se
tiene atención en ese tema también está
el de las terapias de conversión aunque
en el marco del del confinamiento
se han ido dando a conocer cada vez más
casos denunciados por por la pareja o
por por amistades donde dicen a esta
esta joven ha desaparecido y la familia
la tiene recluida en un anexo
con una terapia de conversión y también
el tema que es tan importante que es el
de matrimonio civil igualitario en donde
en méxico solamente ha avanzado en 19
estados de la república de 32 y que por
supuesto juega un tema muy importante
queremos hacer en este tiempo casos en
los que uno de los integrantes de la
pareja ha fallecido por covite sin que
tenga un reconocimiento como familia o
como matrimonio
diferentes y miel y añadió de la crisis
ha venido la familia a despojar y
achacar de la
de lo que habían construido con tantos
años en conjunto esos son el tipo de
casos que de manera cotidiana pues
conocemos y que por supuesto el tema del
matrimonio no es un tema frívolo
hace apenas un par de días se dio a
conocer la declaración del papá
francisco diciendo bienvenidas las las
uniones entre parejas del mismo sexo sin
embargo esas uniones civiles que están
pretendiendo reconocer no son la
equiparación de derechos como lo sería
el matrimonio civil en condiciones de
igualdad y ahí tenemos un falso debate
porque no podemos hacer leyes iguales
con nombres distintos para personas
iguales entonces la suprema corte de
justicia ha dejado claro que debemos
tener el matrimonio civil para parejas
heterosexuales igual que para parejas
del mismo sexo y que por supuesto la
reproducción
no puede ser una condicionante del
matrimonio porque tampoco tendría que
serlo para él para el matrimonio
heterosexual y eso no puede ser una
limitante para que un estado
y siga sosteniendo la desigualdad y la
discriminación hacia personas lesbianas
homosexuales bisexuales y trans eso es
totalmente la igualdad
así es y en contra de los derechos
humanos también mire ya nos estamos
quedando sin tiempo de programa
lamentablemente se nos va muy rápido el
espacio ya para el cierre quisiera muy
rápidamente una declaración suya sobre
la importancia del reconocimiento de la
identidad de género y que a partir de
ahí pues se basa el respeto la
convivencia y estaríamos evitando
situaciones como las que vimos tan duras
en casa frida
así es
el derecho el reconocimiento de la
identidad
es un derecho llave cuando a una persona
tiene reconocida su identidad tiene
acceso a la escuela al trabajo a la
educación y por supuesto a una familia
lo que sucede con las personas trans en
este sentido de no reconocer
jurídicamente su identidad y con ello
por poder
armonizar toda su documentación títulos
universitarios comprobantes de domicilio
etcétera lo único que hace es que abre
un espacio de desigualdad y de violencia
que está totalmente
sostenido
y legalizado por parte del estado es
decir hay un estado en el que está
garantizando casi por un decreto decreto
social un decreto cultural que haya
violencia haya desigualdad y haya
exclusión el derecho a la identidad a
personas trans no puede seguir esperando
más tiempo porque lo que se está jugando
es la vida de las personas
muchísimas gracias a ustedes por estar
con nosotros en ellas hoy a ustedes
continúen con nosotros en france 24 y
volveremos próximamente en ellas hoy
[Música]